you have you're always in like the West
Hollywood area yeah it's not a stir if
you guys haven't been to LA like there's
a huge gay community in the West
Hollywood definitely yes definitely what
they should say about San Francisco it's
like the Castro district it's like the
butthole of definitely the butthole it's
okay yeah I mean for me so she never
would have thought you know initially
wanted to become Abascal you know
playing the NBA set play semi-pro quit
being an actor get survive a job working
West Hollywood and then see what that's
all about and then having these my all
my co-workers be gay and I'm the only
straight guy so every time it's like a
joke like when Easter comes around like
they make fun of you now they make fun
of me yeah I'm the guy like out there
like try and think of like they're like
think about like dinking painting the
room you know the office and like a crew
like the color crew I'm like what the
[ __ ] is that
they're like you don't have a career so
I'm like no it's like oh all right
you're not gay it's like fine you know
you're the odd one right so like my boss
is like super sweet and he'll give us
like you know cookies or whatever from
air1 or something and like it's all like
Easter eggs and then like one chick you
know and like Khalif guess which one's
yours
I'm like the chick yeah cuz you like
girls like yeah okay cool [ __ ] like
bowling us you know so a hetero [ __ ]
they start [ __ ] punking you is [ __ ]
now yeah it's just mob mentality is what
it is I don't even think it's a gay or a
hetero thing it's just a different
people like to pay maggiore that's the
minority yeah the majority always
crushes the minority yeah it's so
[ __ ] funny yeah yes every time so
every time for lunch I always heard
about my co-workers like Grindr stories
and it's just so interesting like just
learning about the world and like
bottoms and power bottoms and like all
this yeah like what's kohli crap and
just show me like what they'd say it's
like dick pics I'm like oh this is crazy
and like 17 year old click Khalif was
kind of like I mean he was because the
majority I was like home I want to tell
his homophobic
I just thought which is funny well
you know fight [ __ ] homosexuality the
black community is its yeah it's taboo
like it's super tablet yeah yeah me get
beat up jumped in all of this yeah I
mean my even my I'm putting my down
blast he's like I don't mind if they're
gay just don't [ __ ] me it's like that
whole mentality okay and why would they
want to fight in the first place that's
like ugly as [ __ ] to you baby here
someone's gay they're gonna be like oh
my god you're gonna try to [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of us that's a stupid a gay they
just can't get this at yeah yeah it was
like what's the [ __ ] you would you know
yeah I'll play varsity yeah I always
find so fast especially this month being
pride just like it's such a beautiful
thing seeing everyone and just on the
streets and really embracing that that
was a we I didn't know we had a Asian
Pride Month oh it was it like last month
asian asian
yeah it's like March or April yeah
nothing it's made I'm always gonna be
Asian that's why I hope you do but you
know I'm just gonna say this but like
there's a lot of [ __ ] agents out there
in one whole month I don't know we need
a [ __ ] to Japan Montana RIA Montana
stay off did you guys even come across
an article about like this petition for
a straight Pride Month